marry good morning thanks for joining us
how long have you had those tickets damn
it's so good to hear your voice talking
to you again it's really nice but we've
had those seats since the dugout Club
was built in 2000
we've been Dodger fans for a lot longer
than that but we've had those seats
since the beginning of the dugout Club
does Larry offer you any food it feels
like he's always eating during the game
funny thing is Mary never does eat much
of anything but I'm gonna tell him you
said that Jerry no he doesn't he doesn't
share he will not share I get popcorn
for him oh okay
it always feels like he's eating
something so now you're the culprit so
I'll blame you what do you hear behind
home plate last night was remarkable
this this fan you know the fans last
night at Dodger Stadium were better than
they have ever been and we have sat
through a lot of playoff games and my
husband and son and I were just down in
Houston for all three of those games we
were in Chicago before that and we were
in Phoenix when we clinched Chicago at
Wrigley can be deafening and there is
nothing like Minute Maid Park
it is so overwhelmingly deafening there
that it's you you just want to get out
because you feel like we got to go home
we came home they can't hear each other
last night at Dodger Stadium I think we
outdid all of them I you're more excited
about the Dodgers and you are anything
else aren't you you know what Dan it has
been so much fun to follow them to get
to know them I mean it it's it's not
like I ever envisioned that the next
chapter of my life would be to be a
Dodger fan it's kind of turned out that
way with October ball in particular but
it it's really a remarkable game and
it's one I know you you know everything
there is to know about sports
I have really come to appreciate the
strategy the what the managers what Dave
Roberts who is such a terrific guy is
trying to do with the team and when
everybody gets on him for pulling Rich
Hill out last week after the third
inning and last night leaving them in
and how gut-wrenching those decisions
are because you know you're just you're
not going to make the right decisions
all the time but there's a strategy
there I love the strategy of okay it's
Chris Taylor gonna bunt or is he gonna
swing at the ball like last night oh my
gosh it was a game saving double so all
of that stuff is fascinating to me and I
love watching right behind the umpire
like we said and I can really judge
pretty well whether it's whether it's a
ball or a strike and you know they just
don't always get it right what are the
other and one of the other celebrities
around you oh you know I'm trying to
think Larry we have had we've had a lot
of different people Jason Bateman sits
down there he is a die-hard Dodger fan
and Arsenio Hall was there the other
night George Lopez I mean yeah these are
buddies of ours have sat with us and sat
in the area there too but from time to
time Tom Hanks will appear but usually
up in this week I like being right on
the field it's it's just so fun to feel
like you're part of the game she's Mary
Hart former Entertainment Tonight host
how often do you hear the following
every day Seton
is that your ringtone on your phone mer
that's so funny Dan but I will tell you
that even going to Wrigley Field all you
know in Houston so many of the Astros
bands the Cubbies fans it was brutal a
year ago when we lost to the Cubs
it was so incredible this year because
they'd come up and say Mary we know what
a loyal fan is my mom we watched you
growing up and it's so great to see you
become such a baseball fan and we're
gonna root for the Dodgers in the World
Series knock them dead
I mean I heard that from hundreds that's
true people if you walk down the street
do you hear the you really do that well
thank you I've been practicing that
compliment it's a great compliment is
there it's like what do you miss the
most about hosting Entertainment Tonight
what I miss the most is my friends there
you know that doing it for almost 30
years
I was I kind of was over covering all of
the celebrity news but I had developed
so many friendships and I I mean I was
hearing from so many of my fellow et et
workers last night I mean I was looking
at I was reading emails and texts last
night like crazy because so many of them
are sports fans and Dodger fans
specifically many of them even worked
whether it was at Fox Sports or ESPN so
they're really knowledgeable about
baseball too and I mean it just I love
it so I miss my friends the most I will
say it took me a good year to get used
to the fact that I was waking up at the
same time which is always very early and
going hmm what am I gonna do today I'm
not heading over the hill to the radford
studio it's that's a very strange
sensation when you leave something you
have done for so many years aren't you
glad you don't to cover the Kardashians
though Mary
very yep
what was the craziest story you covered
it Entertainment Tonight oh gosh the
craziest story I you know I think that
well Anna Nicole Smith craziest story
yeah and you know that was something
Mark Steines fortunately he had to fly
down to the Bahamas and cover all of
that there have been there have been so
many great ones so many sad ones when I
when I got to take the emails and
letters to Richard Richard Pryor as he
was fading away from this life it was so
emotional and I had disliked him
intensely early on in his in my career
because I had the unfortunate fortune I
should say of interviewing him when he
was doing a lot of drugs and I
interviewed him early in the morning he
was so foul but then I got to know him
my husband had produced a series of
specials with him knew him well and when
he got ill and we talked honestly about
how mean he had been we really bonded
and as strange as it sounds he became
the most powerful interview that was
sustained during the last year of his
life because I kept going back and we
would weep together and we would laugh
together and I ended up at his memorial
service doing the video for his memorial
and I will never ever forget that it was
very moving will you cry tonight if the
Dodgers win Mary Hart I think I'm gonna
cry
when we win and I'm not even thinking of
the option I think I might
I am so emotional I got I woke up at
5:00 this morning and I just lying in
bed thinking you know it's the first
World Series Game seven we've ever had
at Chavez Ravine how exciting is that
we'll be looking for you tonight Mary
and keep in mind we're watching what
you're eating you and Larry
okay
Thank You mayor my butterflies are too
strong great to talk to you oh no that's
Mary Hart for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]